we're live hi I'm Chris Gardner I'm the
legal editor at BuzzFeed news coming to
you today live from the Roosevelt Room
of the White House where we are awaiting
President Obama who's going to come
through that door
at any moment we're not sure exactly
when to talk with us about this Supreme
Court and his nominee for the Supreme
Court Chief Judge Merrick garland of the
DC Circuit Court of Appeals we're here
today this is the president's first ever
Facebook live interview and so we're
really excited here at BuzzFeed news to
be talking with the president
and we're also streaming live on YouTube
so we're really excited to have
everybody on all of these new forms of
media watching this interview with the
president that will be coming through
that door at any minute the president is
getting briefed I've been spending all
weekend getting briefed we're both
getting briefed so that we'll be ready
for this interview I got new socks got
my president interview socks my POTUS
tie so we are all ready to have the new
tie have the new socks be ready for the
interview I'm obviously really honored
to be here because this is the White
House where Hamilton pretty much is here
every other week I think at this point
pretty much that's the way it goes
obviously that lin-manuel Miranda was
here back in 2009 singing the first song
from Hamilton and they were just back
here last month for a cast performance
that the first lady was was as excited
as I am about seeing Hamilton and so
that was pretty exciting in Poland now
I'm here today waiting for the president
to come through that door
and talk with us about the Supreme Court
obviously this morning I was at the
Supreme Court we had a pretty exciting
day we had big opinions coming down a
big opinion on the Obamacare
contraception mandate
accommodation for nonprofits that I'm
sure the president is going to want to
be talking about and that's part of what
we're here today to talk about which is
the fact that we do have this Supreme
Court nominee who has been on basically
on hold for the past two months we're
going to be talking with with the
president about what it is that the
White House is looking to do what
they're hoping to do from this and and
what it means to have this nominee
pending in in the last year of his
presidency we're waiting that door is
the the big door where where he could be
coming through at any minute
I've got Dorsey here you can't see him
but I can he is filming from from behind
us here I've got FDR over my shoulder
I've got President Theodore Roosevelt
here we're basically all here in the
room ready for for an exciting interview
as soon as the president comes through
that door so I hope that facebook live
is is getting getting hot or we getting
a lot of people watching waiting for the
president to be coming in YouTube are
you waiting for the president to be
coming in we're going to be starting the
interview as soon as he gets here and
talking about the president's nominee
Merrick garland Judge garland in any
minute when the president comes through
the door everybody
people are coming in the room from from
the White House awaiting the president
so I think I think we might be getting
close
watch the door everybody watching the
door door see are you watching the door
I am on the door
Dorothy is focused on the door so we've
got that set um we are everybody hey
Chris how are you isn't it nice to see
ya thanks for taking the time thank you
for taking the time how are you doing
I'm doing great yeah I like your socks
uh-oh that I can't work cool sucks
because I think you're the president
this is actually they are from Paul
Stewart and they told me if you
complimented the socks or tie I had to
to mention that because they do get
their suits made in Chicago and so they
said if you need a new suit you should
stop by you know I be I think I'm up for
an upgrade yeah after yeah then you can
work a break you can wear whatever socks
you want um well thank you so much for
taking the time we're here on Facebook
live your first interview on Facebook
live on YouTube as well to talk about
your Supreme Court nominee Merrick
garland obviously it we're now two
months today since you and the Vice
President and Judge Garland stood in the
Rose Garden talking about his nomination
and what you were looking for from the
court today we obviously saw from the
court what happens we saw a court that
sent back all of these cases regarding
the accommodation for religious
nonprofits with the contraception
mandate so where where are we where are
we this nomination well that made me
it'd be helpful Chris for me just to
describe for everybody who's watching
why this is important you're a legal
writer I taught law but for a lot of
people sometimes it may not seem that
important but the Supreme Court is the
ultimate judge the ultimate arbiter of
what the law of the land is and you know
that means that it is determining what
the government can or cannot do to
improve the economy it's making
decisions about whether certain groups
of people are being treated fairly we're
not being treated fairly it weighs in on
issues of national security there's no
part of our lives that aren't touched by
the rules that the court puts forward
and there are nine Supreme Court seats
and right now there's one vacant and
historically we have never gone too long
before we fill a vacancy now it's always
politically controversial because people
these days have strong views about
certain issues whether it's gun safety
legislation or abortion or a variety of
other hot-button issues and so between
Democrats and Republicans there have
been a lot of debates about filling
these seats but part of what I tried to
do in filling this seat was to find a
nominee who had unimpeachable
credentials who everybody said was a
great judge and everybody said could
work with both conservatives and
liberals and I found that person in
Merrick garland this is a guy who
currently serves on the second most
important court in the land he has by
all accounts conducted himself fairly
judiciously he works with other people
very wealth he's wicked smart even
Republicans compliment him and say he's
a great judge in the past he's been
confirmed unanimously by the Senate
for the current positions that he holds
he's got more experience on the federal
bench than many of the folks who are
currently on the Supreme Court and yet
despite that in an unprecedented fashion
the Republicans made a determination
that they weren't even going to give the
guy a hearing and they weren't going to
give him a vote now I understand why
that happened you know this seat became
vacant suddenly during an election year
and Mitch McConnell the Senate
Republican leader got nervous because he
figured that some of his constituents
Republicans and folks on the right would
be furious about me
the president United States filling any
filling any Supreme Court seat and
certainly not Justice Scalia's seat and
so he just kind of in knee-jerk fashion
said we're not going to vote on despite
there no precedent for that and now what
we have is a situation where having made
that promise Republicans are looking at
a Republican nominee who many of them
say isn't qualified to be president much
less appoint somebody and it seems to me
that they'd be better off going ahead
and giving a hearing and a vote to
somebody that they themselves in the
past have said is well-qualified is fair
and you know to treat the Supreme Court
with the the seriousness and the sense
that it's beyond politics that it
deserves I mean chairman Grassley of the
Judiciary Committee has acknowledged
that this is a gamble what what the
Republicans are doing with you mentioned
the the nomination of Donald Trump the
presumptive Republican nominee it is is
that you cited to it just now is is that
the best thing that's happened to to you
getting this nominee look I've said this
before I've I think that our country is
better off when the Democratic nominee
for the presidency and the Republican
nominee are both qualified to be
President and can be effective because
you never know what happens I'm a
Democrat I'd prefer Democratic policies
but I want a serious Republican Party
and serious Republican nominees
ultimately will be up to the voters to
make a decision about that but precisely
because this election year has been so
crazy precisely because you have a
number of Republicans who have said that
they're concerned about
their nominee it shows you why you don't
want to politicize a Supreme Court
appoint the Constitution the United
States says whoever is president if
there's a Supreme Court vacancy they
should nominate somebody that's what I
have done I've carried out my
constitutional due the Constitution then
says that it's up to the Senate to
advise and consent to which over the
last several decades has meant that you
meet with the guy or gal find out
whether they're qualified have a public
hearing so all Americans can assess
whether this person has the temperament
the intellect and the judgment to be a
good Supreme Court justice and then you
have abou deep anything that's a
constitutional obligation I do i I
believe that if if the Republicans in
the Senate want to argue publicly that
this man is not qualified to be on the
Supreme Court they should do so but they
can't it would be it would not be a
plausible argument so instead what
they've done is fabricate a new rule
essentially that says we're not going to
nominate or we're not going to have a
hearing or a vote on a nominee during an
election year
well why where'd that rule come from in
fact Justice Kennedy who's currently on
the Supreme Court was nominated by
Ronald Reagan a Republican and a
Democratic controlled Senate approved is
a nomination because they thought even
though we don't agree with a lot of
stuff we do think he's qualified to
judge and we were going to follow he was
already a third nominee for that well
but the again the issue here is nobody's
suggesting that the nominee I'm putting
forward is unqualified they are on
record saying that this is a very well
qualified candidate and in that
circumstance it is up to them in terms
of their constitutional obligation to
have a hearing and have a vote now
here's the good news originally they
said they won't even meet with the guy
and they heard from a lot of their
constituents that said well you know
this isn't kindergarten you don't you
don't just because you're not happy with
what's happened you don't do your job
and so now you've seen already 15
Republican senators meet with dead
garland those who have met with him I
think have been favorably impressed so
my hope is is that the closer we get to
you know the summer and the more
pressure that viewers are putting on
senators just to do their job and give
the guy here and give them a vote then
more and more Republican senators will
recognize that the position they're
taking is not tenable and part of the
reason it's it's you know this is really
a problem is because if if we set a
precedent now where we just don't give a
judge even a hearing or a vote then
let's say a Republican president in the
future is trying to appoint somebody
Democrats are going to do the same thing
and it's going to be tit-for-tat
and we'll pretty soon have a situation
in which we can't fill our Supreme Court
and that then means that laws are going
to be different in different states and
different jurisdictions and people are
going to be confused about what the
rules are that's not our democracy is
supposed to work
you obviously it's it's not just from
Republicans you've spent a large part of
your legacy on judicial nominations as
in diversifying the federal bench you've
appointed more than 150 nominees who
have been confirmed who are not straight
white men you had an opportunity with
this nomination to for the first time in
the nation's history if the Justice was
can
to have a Supreme Court that was not a
majority of straight white men why
didn't you take that opportunity well
because I never think about it in terms
of this seat is for a Hispanic man this
seat is for a gay black woman that he
you know that's not how I think about
those issues what I think is that we
should nominate people who are extremely
well-qualified who have shown themselves
to care about people and care about
justice and when you cast a wide net and
you look at all the people who are
qualified then you're going to end up
with a court that reflects America and
that's what we've done with our District
Court nominees that's what we've done
with our appellate court nominees as you
point out I've appointed more minorities
more women more LGBTQ judges than any in
history but I've done so taking each
appointment and saying who's the best
person for the job at this time and it's
just turned out that by doing so and by
looking at a wide range of experience
not just the traditional they were at a
law school and they were a prosecutor
but also people who were public
defenders or people who were advocates
on behalf of you know workers or what
have you that you do get a broad pool of
candidates in this particular situation
what I was looking for was the best
person for the Supreme Court at this
time and somebody who could bring both
conservatives and liberals together
because we don't want the court being as
polarized as our politics and Judge
Garland was the perfect candidate for
this moment for this particular seat as
you know a previous that I nominated two
women one of them Hispanic tips out of
my aura
all right judge Kagan and Justice Kagan
and they're just doing a great job just
this past week the court split for four
on a decision whether or not to allow an
execution to go forward in Alabama that
there were four justices a lot of people
said if Justice Scalia had still been on
the Portland voting that the execution
probably would have gone forward there
there were some liberal lawyers
including David Mitchell who said that
they had the same concern about judge
garland given his prosecutor past which
you've obviously touted in his
nomination he said he'd rather have an
eight-member court what do you say to
people who have that concern about this
nomination here's the thing Chris what
you don't want to do is to start
thinking about the courts in terms of
how will they come out on this
particular case because judges look at
all kinds of cases and you know judge
Garland's background and experience
means that he cares about public safety
he and there are times where he is ruled
in favor of law enforcement and making
sure that they had the tools they need
to keep us safe there are also times
where he has pushed back against what he
considered to be law enforcement
overreach including by the federal
government and by the president the
United States and his administration so
what you really are looking for is just
a judge who is going to play it straight
and you know apply the law not try to
solve every ill in society that's not
the role of the courts not try to engage
in all kinds of radical steps but rather
just to take the law in the Constitution
and say how does it apply to today with
an understanding that there are
real-life consequences to his or her
decision and I hope one of the things I
look for in my nominees is that they
have some sense of
passion and empathy they're not just
always going to be looking out for the
most powerful in society but there are
going to be thinking about ordinary
people and how the laws impacting them
in a practical way you talk about the
important issues that the judges are
going to notice in deciding obviously in
recent weeks there's been a lot of
attention on transgender people and
obviously your Attorney General spoke
very forcefully about the lawsuit that
the administration is brought against
North Carolina you followed up with
guidance that came from the Education
Department for all schools um there were
governors who responded to that by by
saying that that local official should
disregard that guidance what what do you
have to say to to those governors well
first of all on the on the merits on the
issue itself we're talking about kids
and anybody who has been in school and
in high school who's been a parent I
think should realize that kids who are
sometimes in the minority kids who you
know have a different sexual orientation
or transgender are subject to a lot of
bullying potentially there's they are
vulnerable and I think that is part of
our obligation as a society to make sure
that everybody is treated fairly and our
kids are all loved and that they're
protected and that their dignity is
affirmed and
in this particular situation I won't
comment on the lawsuits that are going
back and forth between the Justice
Department and North Carolina that's
typically not my role I try to with the
Justice Department do its job but with
respect to the department education
schools were asking us we're asking the
Department of Education how should we
handle this so they they they sought out
some clarification some guidance and
that's what we did we said you know what
it is our view that you should try to
treat these kids with dignity here's how
there are school districts who have been
wrestling with this problem and have we
think done a good job in accommodating
them in a way that is good for everybody
and so you can learn from these best
practices this is what we are advising
and you know ultimately depending on how
these other lawsuits go you know courts
will affirm or reject how we see the
issue but we think it was important for
schools who want to go ahead and in a
very practical way try to deal with the
school year what are they going to be
doing next year how should we approach
this that we give them our best judgment
about how to approach it one last
question
we've got our Facebook live audience
here YouTube audience you've obviously
seen a lot with the courts in the
judiciary in your time in office that
has probably changed your views since
you were a law professor since you were
doing that there's been this this effort
from from states from individuals from
the house to to take action against you
and go to the courts against your your
administrative actions do you do you
think that this is something that's
unique to your presidency do you think
that this is part of a in emerging
pattern of how states and others are
going to be dealing with the government
no I mean I look there's a long history
of this if you think about we're in the
Roosevelt Room right now there was a guy
named Franklin Delano Roosevelt his
pictures right over your shoulder who
was dealing with the Great Depression
and was trying to initiate a whole range
of actions to to try to help lift people
out of poverty and give them jobs and
you had a cantankerous court that was
striking down a lot of the rules that he
put forward you know this is part of the
process of our democracy for the most
part even Bush appointed judges have
upheld what I've done on things like
health care and on trying to combat
climate change and trying to make sure
that our justice system is fair
occasionally they disagree and and
that's okay you know it's part of the
process the main thing I want viewers to
understand is that they're really big
stakes to this right now for example we
just had a case that was deadlocked for
four that had to do with whether or not
a married woman had to get a signature
from her husband to get a loan from a
bank to start a business and the
question was whether the Federal Reserve
Bank which oversees our a lot of our
banking system and monetary system along
with some of the other agencies have the
authority to tell banks you know that's
discriminatory you can't treat women
that way you're not treating a man
that way when he's going in for a loan
and because we didn't have a knife judge
justice on the Supreme Court right now
in Arkansas the rule is different than
it is in Tennessee and that's not how
you you want the United States of
America operate states have their own
powers and they can make some of their
own laws but ultimately we also have one
United States law on certain big issues
and the Supreme Court has to be there to
deal with it and what I really want
everybody to understand is that the way
that we keep our judicial system intact
and with the integrity that it has had
and that is admired around the world the
way we maintain rule of law and a sense
that justice is blind and it doesn't
favor one group or another but is
properly interpreting the laws that
Congress passes and the actions that the
president is taking and the language of
the Constitution the way to preserve
that is to make sure that when we
nominate judges they're treated fairly
that we try to minimize the politics and
that well-qualified people can take
those seats and be outside of the
day-to-day scrum of politics and
I think if we're going to maintain that
tradition of judicial integrity and the
integrity of the Supreme Court then I'm
going to need people who are watching to
put pressure on your Senators to say do
your job and just be fair if you're fair
if you're doing your job then I have
confidence that the people I've
nominated or highly qualified and that
they'll continue the tradition of a
judiciary that is not subject to the
same day-to-day polling and politics and
you know nonsense that we see on TV
every day but it's standing above it and
taking the long view it and treating our
democracy a little bit more seriously
that's what we want I know it just
happened today but do you have any
response to the courts action on the
Obamacare contraception mandate well
they basically punted it the circuit the
practical effect is right now that women
will still continue to be able to get
contraception if they are getting health
insurance and we are properly
accommodating religious institutions who
have objections to contraception you
know I I won't speculate as to why they
punted but my suspicion is is if we had
nine Supreme Court justices or might
have been a different outcome
all right thanks Chris Fritz Kuhns thank
you so much majority yeah all right
thank you guys thank you Facebook in
YouTube oh good